I knew him way back in the day with his
tenure with the Green Bay Packers he's
right here on the Rich Eisen show having
followed this pretty much from Jump
Street how are you Andrew I'm good rich
good to be with you and and you I just
start where you just landed there I know
all these years especially since the
case I was sitting there in the Supreme
Court in December
I wondered this question do the NFL NBA
etc want to win this case
or do they want to lose this case
because we are now in a new age where
gambling is on the table and that
presents tremendous revenue
opportunities for these leagues it came
to them probably in the way they weren't
expecting they wanted as you said a
federal result a legislative result
still excuse me still do but the feds
are the legislators not going to get
involved now this is going to be a
patchwork and it's something they've got
to get a handle on despite wanting to
dictate their terms on how gambling
comes in it's now being dictated to them
by the Supreme Court and by the states
well by let's just I guess take it one
step at a time Andrew I mean yeah you
know the NFL as well as I and you know
worked in there I mean they didn't they
didn't call an 800 number for a lawyer I
mean they put Paul Clemente in front of
the the Supreme Court and so I mean I
would think they tried to win and I
think that they you know even with the
revenue opportunities on am Ian Rapoport
tweeting I mean reporting as well and
nfl.com article on this subject today
that the league had presented before it
at the owners meeting in March a
previously secret a a secret
investigation by the league into what
this could mean and patterns of gambling
etc you know I do you really think the
NFL wants something like this this is I
wanted to lose and obviously Paul
Clemente to another speaking of the
Packers big Packer fan from Wisconsin
games yes they wanted to win because
they want a federal framework they
wanted the courts not to be involved in
this they wanted not to be a
state-by-state patchwork the point
generally though is what ian was
talking about these tremendous revenue
opportunities that are going to come
from this and we've seen this with
fantasy the past three or four years
where it is an incredible fan engagement
tool where you're you're watching games
where you have no rooting interest that
will obviously continue with gambling I
was on a panel rich guy from Nielsen
research puts out this statement or this
research average NFL non betting fan
watches 15 16 games a year makes sense
home team average betting NFL fan
watches about 50 games that is gold
literally to the music ears of NFL
executives we're okay we're going to
have all this new interest from gambling
which means revenue which means
continued growth of franchise values all
of the above so what happens next and
you're Andrew Brant here on the Rich
Eisen show having covered this as well
as you have what happens next do you
think well I think those high-priced
lawyers you mentioned and lobbyists are
continue to work Congress to see if
there can be a federal framework to this
but meanwhile it's going to happen and
when I say going to happen New Jersey is
poised they've had Monmouth Park ready
to go spend a million dollars on a
Nevada style sports book I think it
could be open by the NFL
I'm sorry NBA Finals then you have
states like Pennsylvania Delaware New
York Connecticut West Virginia poised
they have bills that have gone through
committees that are ready to go and we
could see action by the NFL season the
problem for the NFL is this is a
patchwork so it is state-by-state does
this present a negotiating opportunity
with the union where marijuana is
state-by-state but not according to the
NFL because that's negotiated with the
Union you can't smoke at least you have
a protocol in place you have a drug
testing program we'll see what happens
there they put out statements like we
want to get involved in this too and
there's going to be a negotiation
so I understand what's going on in
Rogers offices right now how do we
control this how do we monetize in the
right way is it going to be a singular
deal with a sports book is it going to
be some integrity fee with these states
they got to get ahead of it well I love
that phrase integrity fee that's great
lutely
well but because you know look you know
as Ron darling said last hour that
there's always going to be somebody at
the at the low end of the salary
spectrum in a sport that could be
susceptible and wind up being in a game
and throwing it for all the wrong
reasons now that it could be more
prevalent or that could be again an
argument that is being used against
sports gambling that that is not
operative really when it all comes down
to it and the league's are gonna want a
piece the Union wants a piece I mean if
it's all gonna happen the question is is
how do they get their piece I mean is
there gonna be some sort of legal
argument between states that want to
keep it or states that can say we paid
for the stadium so you don't get
anything how does that work now but yeah
these unions and states we've got to
negotiate all this and I think what you
raise is really something I mean
integrity has been the issue for so long
to have this taboo about gambling the
integrity of the game but I do think and
I'm friends with our all these people as
you are I do think they lost moral
high-ground on the integrity issue when
they put a franchise in the gambling
mecca of the country because listen when
I covered those meetings for ESPN I'm
asking owners like what's your concern
about Vegas well is it a sustainable
market is it just a tourism market will
it last and I said well what what about
gambling oh yeah we'll figure that out
and when you have an 800 million subsidy
from Nevada integrity doesn't have that
much strength as it did before so that's
where we are I don't know how they're
going to continue to have this listen
Roger is the conduct commissioner he has
made morality a big part of his tenure
owners not that they're amoral
but they seek the revenues and when we
talk about engaging young viewers
they're gonna look for new ways and
imagine the possibilities with in-game
betting and all the mobile applications
so here we are what if this what if the
state of New Jersey wants to put one of
their new fangled sports betting parlors
inside MetLife Andrew nothing from the
Supreme Court decision today would say
that that's a problem
I mean unless the Giants and Jets
personally owned it right wasn't that
private dollars I'm going through my
head so there well it was a
public-private partnership so that's a
good question I don't know exactly where
that would land let's just say that
there is a publicly owned stadium
somewhere in the National Football
League and that state decides to have
sports gambling can they go ahead and
just put a sports bar parlor or allow
the Wi-Fi app in their state to to have
connectivity within that stadium I would
think that's all there right now if that
state has passed laws and of course it's
maybe it's going to be in the language
of the statute but if those laws are as
broad as New Jersey is proposing its law
then it's yeah it's fair game and it
doesn't have to be casinos Monmouth Park
is a horse racetrack that's ready to go
ready to go outfitted ready to go and
we'll see the whole premise of all this
starting with Adam Silver's op-ed four
years ago is that we want to bring
gambling out of the darkness and the
light they won't be making their bets
with the book in the back of the
barbershop now is you just had the pole
second to change people's betting I
don't know but you know we are at this
place right now where the stigma about
gambling is diminishing last one for you
Andrew from your tenure with the Green
Bay Packers and knowing that front
office as you do the Aaron Rodgers
conversation with this contract what's
what's that about right now what do you
think I think they're into it and and
that's what that sort of gets away any
of this noise that was out there earlier
about he's unhappy because they lost
Jordy and the coach if he was truly
unhappy that wouldn't be negotiating as
they are and now Matt Ryan gives a fresh
data point 30 million a year I would
think it would exceed that although
Aaron has two years left and Matt had
one year left but they're in it and he's
obviously the face of the franchise and
he's obviously someone that they're
going to make the highest-paid player in
the league and I think that will get
done whether it's today or the start of
the season or somewhere in between
but it's gonna happen in the county or
2018 right don't you think yeah and I
think that's my history with Bret we
would never let a contract get for a
player like that get even two years from
expiration and that's where we are right
now yeah in this day and age though I
mean you know that this is a midnight
League now I mean it's crazy it's it's
12:05 League everything's like last
minute or just at the very end and what
I guess then then let me ask you the
last one yeah
the collective bargaining agreement
coming up how much does this ruling
complicate things is there what now
three years out I guess of the next
collective bargaining agreement how much
does today's complicate things or maybe
bring these two sides together well I
think it has to bring it together in
terms of a discussion we know the bigger
picture CBA issues the revenue split the
franchise tag the commissioner power all
those rules are going to be in debate as
they were before but this adds another
element I can picture right now the
league is telling the union hey the caps
going to go up because of all these
increased revenues you should be happy
and if I'm the Union I'm saying that's
not enough the fact the cap goes up
because you make deals with sponsorships
with casinos or whatever happens
integrity fees that's not enough we're
the product we're generating this added
revenue we should get more so we have
another issue and I think like you know
in light of a rice the domestic violence
conversation this should bring them
together now they haven't had a great
history a lot of lack of trust there but
this should bring something out of it
and and don't you think all the sports
unions with all the leagues are gonna
have the same conversation and is it
possible that they can all unionize or
band together to have that
in one voice I mean absolutely and I
think whoever goes first becomes a model
now the best relationship seems to be
atoms silver and Michelle Roberts maybe
that becomes a model if they're able to
get something done on some way of
sharing revenues besides just telling
the players hey the caps going to go up
so we'll say Andrew I'm not going to
lose the number we'll chat soon this
thing's to be quite fluid to say the
least
oh it's a pleasure rich right back at
you there Brandt the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience